could you go over some ways that you've
applied minimalism to your business
specifically your brick-and-mortar
coffee shop now you talk about
brick-and-mortar businesses in your book
right yeah I think too often we often we
think that like well if I want my
business to be legitimate then I need a
storefront or I need an office space or
I need you know a place for clients to
you know whatever it can you talk a
little bit about the this this concept
and how it has metastasized into our to
our culture yeah it's basically running
a business to look good for other people
like that that's really what it seems
like it seems like well if I want my
business to be legitimate then I do need
to have things like an office or like a
nice couch that that people can sit on
while they're waiting to meet with me
and it's like even like even smaller
things like having an office at all for
me I like I don't I don't need an office
I don't meet with people for work like I
just I never most people think I don't
exist because I don't do things in
public very often but it's like I want
to run my business for me I want to run
run my business for what's best for me
and the freedom that I want in my life
that my business can provide and so when
I'm thinking about decisions it's like
is this decision just going to look good
for the outside world in which case
maybe maybe I don't need that or is this
decision going to give me more peace and
freedom it's like yeah okay I want that
one instead of what looks good on
Instagram yeah and so I think the
question then becomes is is the brick
and mortar business necessary with
respect to our coffee shop so we we kind
of this coffee shop in a weird way so
our friends Joshua and Sarah Weaver who
have done a lot of photography for us
fact they did the photo on this book and
I think this one yeah on essential so
they they just did a lot of photography
hired them they're freelance
photographers and also they worked for
this design firm and they were they were
kind of tired of doing what they were
doing and they wanted to find a way to
have a community space and while
what does a community space look like a
bunch of different things but for them
they were really passionate about coffee
and so a community space probably does
require a brick-and-mortar presence
right that was the what they wanted to
accomplish
now we could figure out the where and
the how and the why all those things are
important to ask but they we wanted to
help them open the shop and the way we
want to help is we screened our
documentary down there in st. Petersburg
because Saint Petersburg is where
minimalism all started for us my mother
lived down there I really fell in love
with the community and when she passed
that's where I had to actually deal with
her stuff and and so I really enjoyed
the community down there love the people
is a lot of culture per capita in st.
Petersburg Florida and they're opening
this coffee shop cuz it was pretty much
a coffee desert there was not great
coffee
they were Starbucks and 7/11 and but
there was not there was not a good
another or several but there was not a
great coffee shop back then and so we're
like oh yeah let's help our friends so
we'll go screen our documentary well we
get down there about three days before
it's about to open and they're funding
their final funding had fallen through
and they were like we don't think we're
gonna be able to open the shop we don't
have enough money and so Ryan and I went
to said okay how much money do you need
let's see if we could find a way to
raise it and literally how much money
they needed was about all Ryan and I had
saved for the last out of five or six
years and we just said okay we believe
not in the brick and mortar space we
believe in what you're trying to
accomplish here we believe in you as
people and we want to work with you and
so let's partner in this business and
now we're actually opening a restaurant
with them and in the same space and so
that brick-and-mortar space is it makes
sense you have a restaurant but even
then it's not a it's not gonna be all
that we're doing is very minimalist with
respect to our approach it is it's not
cutting corners but what is the the
Minimum Viable equipment Minimum Viable
customer base that we need we're not
trying to get every person in st.
Petersburg
we're trying to find what is what do we
need in order to have the doors open
pair employees pay the owners a living
wage but also we're not we're not
focused on how do I get a line down the
block I'll have the most popular coffee
shop in town having a brick-and-mortar
business makes sense understanding that
it's also going to man there's there's
more overhead in that business than
there isn't in this far more popular
business that we have called the
minimalists because we have employees
and we have to be there every single day
from open until closed and people call
off and there's insurance and we have to
pay rent and there is heating and air
we've got this big old building and it's
hot as hell in Florida so it costs a lot
to air-condition this place in the
summer yeah and so there are all these
embedded costs that you have to think
about because the margins on coffee are
decent but you have to sell a lot of
cups of coffee in order to pay to
air-condition a place in the summer in
Florida yeah there's that yeah the more
basically the more the more expenses you
have the more responsibility that comes
with it right so you need to make sure
that you do have the ball it's just like
it's kind of similar in my business I
went from having probably 10 to 15
customers a year when I was doing design
for client work to doing products like
books where like I can't sell 10 books a
year and live so I needed to make sure
like ok can I can I make sure that there
is a volume there like am I going to be
able to reach enough or am I currently
reaching enough people to be able to
move into a product business where there
does need to be bought like there just
needs to be volume in that kind of
business and if the answer is yes and ok
yeah it makes sense but I still like
make sure I keep my expenses as low as
possible I don't have an office space I
live pretty leanly so I know that like
even if it's a like slow month with book
sales that it's going to be ok and then
I also for my own business I also kind
of diversify it's like diversifying in
investments it's like I don't know how
to invest in individual stocks but if I
just use index funds then it's kind of
investing in everything and then it's
kind of diverse
right so in my business I have podcasts
that generate a bit of income courses
books software company so it's easier to
see like okay well if one thing isn't
doing as well then other things will
hopefully pick up the slack and then
it's just as long as I keep the expenses
down and I don't think like well
illegitimate best soon as you start
thinking like all the legitimate
business needs X then it's like then you
get into tricky territory or even things
like mailing lists like I prune my
mailing list all the time if people
aren't opening my emails are not getting
value from them so I can delete them and
people like well how do you like how do
you get over like deleting thousands of
people from e mailing list and like they
cost me money like if they're getting no
value from it if I'm getting if I'm only
having to pay for people who don't get
any value from the things I'm writing I
you bet I'm gonna delete them like I
feel good removing them they're not
gonna get emails they don't want anymore
I'm gonna be paying for people that are
getting emails they don't want anymore
so I keep my costs low
you